the jurgen experience i mean making bad
decisions based on what other people
think you think what other people think
you should do it i think it's pretty
common supercomp i mean when we when we
started the band there was definitely
decisions that we were making based on
what we thought other people thought we
should do right at one point we got
offered you know to put a song in a
mayonnaise commercial
in the uk
we were keep in mind like we might have
had a couple hundred dollars in our bank
account we were destitute and we didn't
like have
you know there was no other like
lifeline it was like this was our
livelihood
and we were convinced fully by someone
who was working with us as a manager
that if we took that money and we had a
song in our in that commercial that we
would be
branded as sellouts and that we would
never no longer have a career
jesus christ so we didn't and then we've
eventually learned to like it was like
we were brainwashed we were brainwashed
you know because we were making records
by ourselves in our basement like on
absolutely no budget well this guy this
guy lived in like a multi-million dollar
house in the like a big major city and
he was one telling us what you know i
was just like
oh yeah yeah
but yeah you know
is that is that a real dilemma like for
when an artist gets an offer to sell a
song for something like hot dogs
but it's a shitload of money
what is what is the thought process that
happens it seems like it was a thing
when we started it doesn't matter at all
anymore it doesn't seem like it so no
one cares anymore
they shouldn't care when it happens it
doesn't make it it's not it doesn't ruin
the original song
unless you have i think certain songs
were ruined by commercials like oh they
like make a parody of it i heard it
through the grapevine i think was oh
that's that's a rough one there's a
problem there although i still i love
the song still but yeah but you know i
think it's true though you do now have
to think about the grapes dancing around
yeah i don't think about the grapes man
good for you thank you i'm glad you're
there well i don't really either i think
as long as you're
uncomfortable with it but yeah we were
definitely convinced multiple times one
thing we were told not to do was
it was a kate moss jewelry commercial we
were told it was like kate moss like
dancing around scantily clad and we were
told
once again like we'd be a sellout for
doing that
and we didn't or he our manager had
passed on it without asking us and i was
like what the [ __ ]
huh
dude i've done a total 180 after you
brought up the grapes no i agree
yeah i can [ __ ] up a song i guess i
didn't think it could i didn't think
like selling it to a commercial could
and then i thought about the grapes i'm
like
it's just i think it's it's not so much
the commercial as much as that that
commercial was omnipresent it was over
exposure you know here in the sun
hearing the song enough will make it a
hit song i think like
i'm convinced you can put any song pipe
it through every walgreens and it's
gonna become a hit how about that really
big [ __ ] song
absolutely
you can see people dancing to the eye
definitely in france or somewhere where
they don't speak english
you know like a big oh do you hear that
[ __ ] song
well what makes a hit today because of
the fact that radio is not the big
driver anymore what is the biggest
driver of uh
record sales or of of streams of like
how do people find out about stuff now
most i mean
there's this uh
kind of punk
garage
rock musician
who goes by the name king khan on the
barbecue show he actually has the second
most
tick-tocked song right now which is
amazing
so i don't know if that but i i don't
know i don't think any of those like
analytics work anymore to determine
what's happening
i i don't think anybody really knows
what's going on with someone but how
does like say if you're an artist you're
talented how did how the [ __ ] does it
get out there that's what we've we've
wondered
i don't know but you know what's
interesting to me is how many musicians
are selling like they're publishing if
like if we're always told like oh yeah
record sales are
no one's buying records but again you
see like these people selling they're
publishing for like 150 million 500
million bruce springsteen just sold
everything for half a billion dollars
um
yeah he wants a submarine so he wants
that submarine well what's that
somewhere there's a lot of inflation
he's not getting [ __ ] now he's gonna be
up there dressed like tonetta just
dancing
[ __ ] giant yacht
half a billion dollars is a crazy amount
of money but i guess
you know what is bruce springsteen like
in his 60s somewhere right i don't know
my friend said he's the only working
class hero who wants to be known as the
boss
that's a good point yeah that's a good
point
you